this is really important this next story
um when there's a conclusion of sorts to
a major story
it's really important to follow up on it
and this week what some previously
dismissed with this stupid term
russiagate
has been confirmed as very much not a
hoax and you know it never gets as much
attention when the report comes out
because you've got to read it the
corrections never get as much attention
as the headlines we know this is a
reality in media
but the senate select committee has
published its report about russian
meddling in the 2016 election
and it confirmed a lot now i'm not
expecting any apologies from the
lunatics who personally attacked me
and misstated what i claimed was the
situation
this is not about me but i hope that we
can get into the record
all of the things that were not a hoax
and were very much true
and what the senate report found is a
direct continuation of where robert
mueller's investigation
arguably stopped short and didn't go far
enough
we got the fifth and last volume of the
report on russia yesterday
and it shows without a doubt that there
has been no vindication of donald trump
or his campaign
now we know well let me back up
we already knew from the mueller report
that donald trump was not exonerated
on obstruction we knew that from
mueller's report
but this report from the senate select
committee goes so much further remember
as
we dive into this this is a senate
controlled by republicans right now this
is not some left-wing partisan
perspective although certainly democrat
mark warner played a big role in seeing
this through
republican richard burr seems to have
behaved relatively morally in all of
this but
even without full cooperation from the
white house
and whoever else what the report
uncovers is extensive and it's just not
getting the attention it deserves
despite paul manafort's lies throughout
the investigation
they confirmed that paul manafort and
constantine
kilimnik a russian agent were in daily
contact
during the trump campaign they were
coordinating period they were
communicating through encrypted
technology
designed to automatically erase their
correspondence after it took place wow
that's interesting but the real
bombshell here
is that kilimnik was likely a player in
the kremlin plan
to hack and leak the hillary clinton
emails yes
oleg deripaska was connected to the
hacking
but vladimir putin directed the way
in which the hack was going to be
weaponized and carried out yeah
this is what the report found putin knew
and was directing at a high level this
is according
to a senate committee controlled by
republicans
yes roger stone and julian assange from
wikileaks were intermediaries to all of
this
so you can come back and say but david
trump and putin didn't personally set
anything up i don't know who alleged
that they did
certainly not on this program roger
stone knew
as early as august of 2016 that
wikileaks had hacked john podesta's
emails
and when the access hollywood grab em by
the you know what tape came out
they decided let's dump these now
because the timing is opportune the
report exposes that trump lied
in his written testimony to robert
mueller about not remembering
conversations with roger stone of course
since then trump has
commuted the sentence of roger stone in
stone's conviction so again
expectations and avoiding hyperbole
we by that i mean reasonable people
like me said from day one guys
that this is not going to lead to donald
trump's removal
if you're expecting the russia probe to
uncover video of trump red-handed
colluding with putin personally
that was never going to happen because
it didn't happen
if you were expecting trump to be
removed because of the investigation
that was never going to happen
but if you believe and i think as early
as april of 2017 i was saying that
but if you believe that trump basically
has a thing for putin
and other dictators and he's just easy
to manipulate
and the trump campaign was connected to
russia
through wikileaks in this hacking and a
lot of other details
the senate report finds that it did
happen and don't forget trump asked on
live tv
that russia hacked hillary's emails they
did that wasn't
trivial that actually you don't have to
look too deep
he said it publicly and it's what
happened and manafort was in touch with
kilimnik and it it all happened okay
so then the question is what now nothing
i mean they're not going to be held
accountable just put it out of your mind
the accountability would be
voting trump out in november relegating
trump to being
a one-term president who leaves after
one term with a disastrous record
and embarrassed of course he will
because of his narcissism find some way
out of it but who cares
it's for the good of the country that's
what we have left either trump has made
a one-term president
or trump is rewarded with another four
years that's what it is
sunday is the 15th anniversary of the
david pakman show we'll be doing a
one-day membership special
i hope you'll partake a sign on to our
newsletter
at davidpakman.com and sunday afternoon
you'll get an email telling you
how to take advantage of this insane
possibly illegal certainly immoral
membership discount just get uh grab
that newsletter subscription for free
at davidpakman.com one of our sponsors
today
is vincero watches and they're giving
you up to 30 percent off
everything in their store when you go to
davidpakman.com
slash watch if you're looking for an
awesome way to update your look
the perfect way to do it is with an
elegant high quality
wrist watch when there's a company like
vincero
there is no reason to go spending
thousands of dollars on
a watch vincero is an american company
that's made it possible to own
an excellent watch without breaking the
bank all of their watches
are masterfully built with high-end
materials
but they're all in the range of about
150 to 250 bucks
i just got a watch from their icon
automatic collection
the one i got is in gunmetal and slate
blue
i love the look it's sleek classy it's
clear that a lot of careful
craftsmanship went into the design
it is definitely my new favorite watch
you'll get up to 30 percent off
everything in their store
when you go to davidpakman.com
watch i've put the link right underneath
this video